first of all I couldn't even believe you
agreed to be roasted I I watched the
roast was funny as [ __ ] but I mean you
took a lot of hits yeah and you know the
only person on the roast by the way I
think it's worth mentioning that
everybody else in the room and the
producers would come in other comics
come and they have their own stuff too
yeah but they would sit down and some of
the writers would say to me so and so
wants to know it doing what's your cool
with this line and I say yeah okay but
the only one who said verbatim every
horrible thing that was hand to them was
my daughter our own oh my god she handed
a script and she just you could just
tell she put her golf shoes on the [ __ ]
out of you I mean are you sitting there
I see you you seem to be in good spirits
and you're laughing but are you acting
laughing or you saying this is just
[ __ ] brutal I I'm I'm just counting
the minutes to the [ __ ] thing is over
I'm real yeah and here I was next to me
by the way I'll never forget I'm over
here Eddie rose in a chair like this
hey about 30 minutes it is we're only
half an hour record Antony returns me
goes this long long DeNiro decided to do
it I think because he loves you but also
maybe he heard you're doing it for
charity so he said okay I'll sit there
now Nero is a sweet guy what did you
meet because Nikki tells the story she
was on here after the roast boys he said
yeah she read a lot of the jokes she
didn't do which I always loved which we
sprayed Alec you're so East Coast I love
it as a New Yorker I just appreciate
that about you in the Big Apple we have
a saying but it's not spring until you
see Alec Baldwin handcuffed in cargo
shorts Nikki Glaser blew me away
she got up there she was like a skeet
shooting person she was like oh oh oh
shot she is for now I would I walked out
of there going I want to work with her
did anybody there say anything that
offended you to the point that you
turned the Comedy Central so listen
you're not [ __ ] airing that or did
you just let it go
it was cool everything was cool we're
gonna take the Empire State Building and
shove it up my ass right one brick at a
time